well now to an unusual battle in the art
world over of all things a banana an
artwork featuring the fruit by the
italian artist Maurizio Cattelan had
been sold for more than $100,000 in
Miami but then a rival artist took the
banana off the wall and ready for this
he ate it
GWS Alex Flores whiting has the story
and she's here in the studio with me now
to explain the song Alex I have to say
when I first saw this headline I thought
this must be some sort of a joke but the
story is for real isn't it it is for
real and it's all about a banana just
like this
that was bought in a local grocery store
it was stuck to a wall using duct tape
so just like this as part of an
installation at the Miami Art Festival
known as Art Basel and then another
artist came along his name is David tur
tuna who referred to himself as the
hungry artist he decided that this
banana looked good enough to eat he
pulled it off the wall he peeled it and
he began eating it and by then a crowd
had gathered around him obviously wanted
to take photographs working out what was
going on and then a rather flustered
member of staff came along and asked him
to go with her which he truly did I mean
this whole thing just sounds completely
surreal and somebody apparently paid 120
thousand US dollars for this banana
stuck to the wall I mean who would spend
the kind of money let me tell you it's
not just one person three people spent
that kind of money because they had
limited editions of this banana a piece
of artwork and obviously the person who
bought it well he was a French collector
you'd think he'd be very unhappy about
what happened and the fact that this
banana was eaten but actually apparently
it was not about the piece of fruit is
about the idea of the banana and every a
limited piece of artwork came has come
with a certificate of authenticity
meaning that the artist can replace it
when the fruit gets overripe or in this
case is eaten but it's very clear that
the staff were not happy about
what happened he was not arrested but we
had him to leave the booths and to leave
the fair and we have this contact and
everything so we can go we can go
further but I don't think I don't think
we will all right I'm still trying to
wrap my mind around all of this I mean
perhaps that is the purpose of an
artwork like this maybe this is why it's
worth so much money
still not sure about that now this
artist Maurizio Cattelan he is known for
these kinds of unusual artworks isn't he
this is not the first time that no it's
Noah first and he's quite well known
from 18 karat gold functioning toilet
anew and it was put in place back in
September a Blenheim Palace that's a
stately home near Oxford in England but
it was unfortunately stolen there six
people have been arrested in connection
with it unfortunately they haven't found
it but he obviously knows how to call
controversy all right DW Ellis for us
waiting thank you so much for bringing
us up-to-date on this very unusual story